his first ever tv interview we are
hearing now from the gunman who tried to
assassinate president ronald reagan 41
years ago
john hinckley is his name john hinckley
jr and he changed the course of u.s
history in 1981 when he shot and wounded
the president and three other people
outside a washington dc hotel he was a
mentally ill 25 year old and after 30
years at a psychiatric facility
hinckley's restrictions were gradually
lifted and earlier this month a judge
granted him
full freedom hinckley sat down with our
major garrett for an interview you will
only see on cbs news major good morning
we know his name we know his face we
have never heard his voice
good morning tony one of the bullets
that hinckley fired ricocheted off the
presidential limousine entered ronald
reagan's body and lodged within an inch
of the president's heart nearly killing
him hinckley told us he thought the
president was a nice man and a good
president those are direct quotes but
that his mental illness left him deeply
divorced from reality
i went to the
washington hilton hotel
and he came out from giving a speech
and i was right there and i fired shots
at him
which
so unfortunately hit other people too
do you have any recollection of that
feeling at that moment no
no
i don't it's such another lifetime ago i
can't tell you now the emotion i had you
know right as he came walking out i just
can't tell you that
mostly that is something you can't
remember
right
because you don't want to remember it
maybe maybe but you're right it's
something i don't want to remember
it was all just so traumatic the
assassination attempt sent president
reagan to the hospital for nearly two
weeks
paralyzed white house press secretary
james brady and wounded police officer
thomas delahanty and secret service
agent tim mccarthy i shot four people
and i'm sorry to the reagan family the
brady family
the the other families
of the victims
started jodie foster for bringing her
into this hinckley depressed isolated
and delusional was obsessed with actress
jody foster by attempting to kill
president reagan he thought he could
impress her i feel badly about that what
about the reagans
i feel badly for all of them i mean i
mean i have true remorse for what i did
i know that they probably can't forgive
me now
but i just want them to know that i am
sorry for what i did
have you ever thought about what would
have happened had you succeeded
well yeah i mean yeah history would have
been changed with the new you know new
president
that's it
i mean yeah it would have been a big
historical
event
um
i'm glad i did not succeed you are oh
yes
very much so
you traumatized a nation too i did are
you sorry for that yes
i'm sure the country was traumatized i'm
very sorry for that
is there any part of you that
wonders how the john hinckley of that
era could have gotten to that point
i did not have a good heart i was doing
things that you know
a good person doesn't do so
it's hard for me to at all to relate it
all to that person back then a jury
found hinckley not guilty by reason of
insanity and he spent more than 30 years
at a mental institution in dc he was
released to his mother's care in 2016
and granted full freedom earlier this
month is your story
and your freedom justice
yes why is it just
because i was i was not just a coal
calculating criminal in 1981 i truly
believe i had a serious mental illness
that was preventing me from knowing
right from wrong back then hinckley
believes decades of treatment and
medication make him no threat today i've
been in hundreds maybe thousands of
therapies
individual and group
i've been the most scrutinized person
in the entire mental health system
for 41 years
is one of the reasons you're sitting
down with me to try to soften the public
perception yes
i'm just trying to show people
i'm kind of an ordinary ordinary guy
he's just trying to get along like
everybody else if he just thinks i'm
just some
crazy person i'm not that anymore at all
the reagan family brady family and
representatives for jody foster did not
reply to our request for comment
do you think you'll ever
have a chance to get closure with them
i don't know i really don't think the
brady family or the reagan family or
jody foster i don't think they want to
hear from me would you like them to
consider forgiving you yes
they probably can't but i wish i wish
they would
do you want to give them a reason to i
feel terrible terrible for what i did
and
i've had remorse for many years for what
i did and if i could take it all back i
would i swear i would take it all back
hinkley lives alone with his cat theo
whom he calls his best friend he hopes
to create a career as a
singer-songwriter three venues had small
concerts booked for hinckley but they
were all cancelled due to concerns for
security hinckley's and the audiences
and for the foreseeable future hinckley
tells us there'll be no public
performances guys
yeah major it is interesting to hear
from him after all these years to hear
what he was thinking or better what he
was not thinking i can see why the
families don't want to talk to him but i
think the public wanted to know exactly
what was going on and with
i don't mean this in a disrespectful way
but he seems still on medication is he
is he
okay mentally he seemed heavily
medicated to me
so i asked gail if he was taking any
medication specifically for his
psychiatric illnesses he said he's
taking two pills a day and he has sworn
to his therapist and his doctors that he
will stay on those meds he believes he
is better and more stable i think
everyone can see he has kind of a flat
affect and that might be the result of
not only the medication but long-term
therapy i don't know he didn't seem
threatening to me but we wanted to get
his appraisal of this situation and get
his apology on the record if we could
and that's what we did and that's what
you did well he clearly knew what you
were asking and clearly wanted to say
something thank you major appreciate